quite a while ago now the story last
took us through the fei lao manhunt
where after we had taken down her four
rogue agents we caught up with her as
she was attempting to flee the area
following her murder of president ellis
while i believe there is enough
information to say otherwise the general
message that the story was trying to get
across is that we had killed her
and since then we've pretty much had
nothing
however finally after all this time it
has been confirmed that we'll be getting
a further extension to the story but in
what direction nothing has officially
been released
after playing through the first week of
the pts there have been a couple of
hints that have been uncovered towards
the story of the upcoming season 9
content those with a keen eye would have
noticed something new under the comm
section a new manhunt called hidden
alliance where we have another 21
collectibles to find
while this doesn't mean a huge amount on
its own we also need to consider what
we've been able to play during the pts
countdown
near the end of the game mode just
before you extract you are greeted by
the black tusk who are being supported
by a group of hunters
although this isn't new as we saw this
in the barden shaffer manhunt we're a
single hunter who was referred to as the
asset by natalia sokolova when talking
to barton schaefer there was a shadow of
a doubt as to whether the hunters were
actually working with the black tusk or
it was just a one-off hunter who had
broken away from the group acting on his
own
however this seems to have been
clarified by the countdown game mode
showing quite a number of different
hunters fighting alongside them
this is further supported by the killed
by message that pops up when killed by
one of the hunters
as you can see it shows not just the
hunter logo but the black tusk logo as
well it also labels them as black tusk
so the most obvious conclusion as to why
the upcoming manhunt is called hidden
alliance would be that the hunters have
now fully teamed up with the black tusk
and that we'll be seeing a lot more of
them
but what if this is too obvious
we've already assumed that this was the
case following the bad and shaffer
manhunt
maybe there is another alliance that's
about to be formed something that we
don't expect
yes if you couldn't tell by now this is
going to be another one of those videos
where i dust off the old tinfoil hat and
spin some wild speculations on where the
hidden alliance manhunt could take the
story
it has been quite a while since the
shaffer manhunt so a lot of people have
probably forgotten that he wasn't killed
in that fight just critically injured
up until this point he has been held
captive by the shd and while we all know
that he was working with sokolova
perhaps he didn't know the full story
natalia sokolova grew up in russia her
father alexei sokolov was an
industrialist who remarried to an
american woman and moved to the u.s with
natalya's younger half-brother felix
while natalya stayed behind to run the
business
after her father's death natalya
inherited his fortune
felix was forced to join the navy by his
father and after studying medicine at
university he was recruited by the shd
there is a good chance that natalia was
aware of the shd long before the
outbreak
for unknown reasons she would go on to
form the black tusk who had been largely
responsible for the events that have
happened since before the outbreak even
occurred
so what does this have to do with barden
schaefer
well barton comes from a family with a
long and proud tradition of serving the
country
since the age of 19 he was enlisted with
the united states army where he quickly
rose through the ranks
he served multiple tours of iraq and
afghanistan and was widely respected by
the men under his command
baden is a true patriot and he believes
in doing what is best for his country
over everything else
after retiring from the army baden was
made an offer to join a pmc
called the black tusk
before their operation against the
united states government began baden was
convinced that the country needed saving
from the corruption coming within that
their job was to remove the rotten corps
and reinstate leadership that would
bring the u.s back to its former glory
baden's involvement with natalya was
likely to be relatively minimal up until
this manhunt he had his own commanding
officer to report to
but even if it wasn't it's unlikely that
she had shared her true intentions with
him not that we know exactly what those
are but it can be safe to assume that
it's likely to be a russia versus u.s
type situation as this follows a lot of
the tom clancy's narrative and the
division story was inspired by his work
plus if her story has anything to do
with it she does have the potential
there to have some sort of beef with the
united states
her father did presumably divorce her
mother and remarry to an american woman
who then took him and her younger
brother away to the u.s where eventually
she would be convicted of murdering
natalya's father
the hidden alliance could be that barden
schaefer learns of natalya's true
intentions against the country that he
loves and breaks away bringing with him
a large portion of the black tusk that
are loyal to him
so we could be seeing a more balanced
conflict in the days ahead where we'll
see the division barden and the black
tusk versus natalya the remaining black
tusk and the hunters
this alliance could also involve someone
who may or may not still be alive
feylau
it wouldn't be one of my speculation
videos if i didn't give any really out
there ideas
i talked about this in a previous video
but what if aaron keena isn't really
dead
a lot of us have been mourning the
potential death of our favorite
antagonist especially when considering
the disappointing direction his story
took
in the cutscene where keena dies we see
the player agent and kelso who was
talking to him trying to understand what
he had just done with his watch
when suddenly isaac announces rogue
agent deceased
the agents then leave the scene without
so much as even checking his pulse
while i struggle to believe that
everything we saw in that cutscene was
everything that happened that kina's
body was just left as is
that a character of his importance
wouldn't have been extracted by the jtf
later on to be examined it certainly
wouldn't be the first time that a
villain has been brought back from the
dead
hornet is the most obvious example of
this but hornet was a minor character at
this stage and him suddenly being alive
didn't really have that much impact on
the story
a major character like kina coming back
from the dead just seems a little bit
too comic book and overused
however i can see both sides of this
argument
we're definitely supposed to believe
he's dead but there are a few pieces to
the story that could explain how he
could still be alive that actually isn't
too unrealistic regarding the narrative
direction
the first question do we know that we
actually killed keener in the first
place
we certainly killed someone
someone who sounded like kina
someone who we assume looked like
i'm not going down the path of body
doubles or surgical manipulation or
anything but there is the possibility
that the man who died on the dock wasn't
actually the man himself i mean our
agents have never actually met kina face
to face
agents that had either joined him or
were killed
we've only heard from him through
recordings and grainy videos and echoes
which to be fair he looked quite
different in a number of them
however before i get too crazy with all
this and start digging way into the
conspiracy theories let's jump back to
the story
before we landed on liberty island we
confronted kina's rogue agents
one of them being theo parnell
theo was a tech genius and while we were
actively hunting him down he proved time
and time again that isaac couldn't be
trusted he showed how easy it was to
manipulate the ai into doing reporting
and saying whatever he wanted it to
this is a big part of how theo's special
tech the decoy works
following on from theo's death kina or
whoever we were fighting showed again
how easy it was to control isaac by
having it relay anything that he wanted
it to straight into our earpieces
it's entirely possible that theo and
kina had orchestrated the whole plan
that we the agents were meant to catch
up with kino on the island and take him
down
or at least think we had
so what was the point in faking his
death
to buy himself some time similar to what
he did on the west side piers
to create a distraction while he
continued with his plans except through
having everyone think he was dead the
division and black tusk would no longer
be looking for him turning their
complete attention on each other
perhaps things were getting a little too
hot for him after his betrayal of the
black tusk and this was his contingency
plan to get the heat off his back and
the only other person that knew of this
was theo which is why keena was happy to
let him die at the hands of the division
from here keena may be continuing to
build his network of rogues
when you think about it we've only met
so many so far there are likely hundreds
if not thousands more of them out there
don't get me wrong i'm really not a fan
of the whole surprise he isn't dead idea
but i certainly wouldn't be upset if
keena comes back into the picture he was
definitely one of the more interesting
characters of the story and this could
help us understand the unusual
directions character took at the end
there
but if they do go down this path they'd
have to do it right because personally
and i know for a lot of others too this
could break the immersion of the story
if it was done half-assed
there are a number of holes in the story
that would need to be plugged in order
to have this work
so perhaps this hidden alliance is
between kina and the division
he was always more aware of what was
going on in the government than the rest
of us and about the black tusk and their
motives
maybe now that the shd is finally caught
up with what is happening it is now time
for kinah to resurface and bring them in
on his plans
[Music]
as i said at the beginning i think the
most likely direction this will go will
be around natalya the black tusk and
their alliance with the hunters
i think this season will be one that is
centered around the hunters
it's likely we'll be receiving a lot
more information about them and their
origins though not everything there will
still be an air of mystery around them
this also doesn't confirm to me that the
hunters are black tusk just that they're
working with them
the leading argument is still that they
potentially have origins in russia in
some form
anyway i think i've been down the rabbit
hole for long enough now so i think i'll
wrap this one up before i completely
lose the plot on the plus side hopefully
this has helped refresh your memory on
some of what has happened in the story
up until now
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch in the next one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]